from the university of sherbrooke it's
going to tell us about classical
simulation of quantum made by assistance
professor networks okay thank you very
much Andrew yeah yes so I'd like to
thank the organizers first of all for
putting this together and having me here
so today will be when my talk will be
kind of an overview talk on some of the
limits of what we can do with classical
simulation of quantum many-body systems
so the first question we might ask is
why do we care about classical
simulation and at least for the moment
like quantum computers have made a lot
of progress quantum simulators have made
a lot of progress but they're still not
quite there even if even if they do
become much better classical computers
are still going to be more abundant and
cheaper so it really makes sense from a
practical perspective to explore what
can be done with classical simulation
methods even even if these things do
become much more feasible and from a
theoretical perspective like more
fundamentally we want a good
understanding of what classes of quantum
sumit system can be simulated and why so
even if these things get really good we
still want to have this theory of what
makes quantum systems difficult to
simulate classically so this question of
what can be done classically really
depends on how much a lot of this
question depends on how much rigor you
want to bring to it whether you're a
computer scientist or really a physicist
physicist so if you're at the high level
of rigor you care about efficient
simulation a theory you want algorithms
that provably converge in polynomial
time you want rigorous error bounds you
want to classify complexity classes you
maybe don't care that things aren't
practically viable like is that a talk a
few weeks ago and they were discussing
an algorithm they're scaled as the
number of qubits the power of 200 which
is still technically efficient but it's
not going to be much use from our
practical perspective when you go to the
other side you could you really if you
want an efficient simulation and
practice you want good results on sort
of reasonable time on current hardware
you may not need
thoroughly care whether you can prove
things or not or whether you even
understand why something works so just
to set the scene today we're going to be
somewhere in the middle where we want
methods that could be or are practically
viable and yet also still have a good
understanding a good theory of why why
these things work if not rigorous proofs
if you do want to understand more of the
practical side of things I would suggest
this paper sponsored by the Simons
collaboration on the many electron
problem so comparing a whole bunch of
methods for the two-dimensional hubbard
model so you have a ton of methods say
comparing the ground state energy so
couple cluster DMR G Monte Carlo
hartree-fock or all kinds of things and
there's a follow-up paper in which they
say and compare methods for the a 1d
hydrogen chain again a ton of methods
they go through all the details of what
works and where many comparisons so
let's get started on the talk proper
okay so we have a qubit a two-level
quantum system of course a state on the
cubed is just specified by two complex
numbers complex amplitudes for the zero
and the one for two qubits we have four
numbers three qubits we have eight four
we have sixteen ok so I'm just so a
wavefunction in a local basis on some
number of qubits is described by some
tensor which is just a coefficient for
each of the binary strings of basis
States okay very simple so clearly we
need exponentially many parameters to
fully describe a wave function in this
local basis so what can be done
classically if we want to do everything
exactly so a five by five lattice very
easy on a laptop
six by six we could do it on a
workstation maybe if we have around 100
gigabytes seven by seven this is roughly
the limit of LAN choice today like if
you have a very powerful supercomputer
if you have maybe have many symmetries
in your problem this is something that
you could do
classically however of course
exponential scaling so things roughly
get out of control we're never going to
be able to do big systems this way so 10
by 10 we have the number of bits and
memory is comparable to the number of
atoms in a human being or the number of
atoms in a solar system for a 14 by 14
or the number of atoms in the observable
universe
okay so describing an exact wavefunction
on in qubits this is not a wrap we want
to take so we need to make some
approximations when we do this and of
course there are many different types of
approximations you can make depending on
the physics one of the most reasonable
as to to make approximations in terms of
entanglement we can see very easily why
this may work so if I have a just a
generic entangled state on in qubits its
described by this to the in coefficient
tensor however if I have a product state
on in qubits its specified by order in
parameters I just described each state
individually so you can see here that
the the difficulty in representing a
quantum state is somehow related to the
entanglement if I have no entanglement
then it's just a very simple product
state I have so so there may be some
hope of sort of going in between these
two extreme cases where I can still have
some amount of entanglement and still do
things efficiently ok so this brings us
to the question of how much entanglement
is present in relevant quantum states
the types of things we may care about
and for the purposes of today's talk
we're going to think about quantum
states quantum many-body systems on the
lattice so imagine I have a lattice 1 D
2 D of spins or qubits or fermions and
I'm just thinking about having a local
interaction so things interact with
their neighbors or the next nearest
neighbors so forth so local interactions
and we're interested in ground state
physics or very low energy physics low
energy excitations and and in the vast
majority of cases the ground States are
entangled they're not going to be simple
products
however there's lots of structure in
this problem given from these local
interactions okay so I have a system
where the spins interact locally what
what this the structure that this gives
to the ground state is that spins will
be very strongly correlated or entangled
with nearby sites but less and less
strongly correlated as some sites
further and further away so this is sort
of our intuition we can make this more
rigorous that one way to think about
this is in terms of block containment
entropy so the von Neumann entropy of a
reduced density matrix for some
subsystem of of this lattice I'm
imagining either state on this lattice
if I just chose a random state from the
hilbert space say according to the haar
measure I would get the entanglement of
the block would scale as the size of the
block directly so a bulk scaling what we
observe and what has been sort of more
formally proved by Hastings is that if
we have a 1d gapped Hamiltonian the
entropy scales as the boundary of the
block so we can think about this we have
some short correlation length it's only
things near the boundary that block that
in contributing to entanglement so it
doesn't matter how big this blockers
being Tanglin still saturates
at some upper bound okay if we have a 1d
gapless Hamiltonian the most usual case
is that we have a logarithmic scale of
entanglement okay so we have growth in
Tang when there grows with the block
size much less than the bulk law buts so
growing without bound so these
correspond to conformal field theories
in general however there are other
behaviors possible in the case of
gapless you can have very sort of
pathological things but this is the most
typical behavior okay so gapless you
have polynomial correlations so things
even with deep within the block still
contribute to this block and Tanglin
entropy
if a 2d systems again you have something
very similar where if I if I have a 2d
lattice some state ground state if I'm
looking at how much in tang winters say
an L by L block have in this 2d ground
state this is not something we can prove
rigorously anymore but at least for say
this is observed in the vast majority of
cases then we have some say rigorous
proof for free Fermi on systems so if we
have a gapped Hamiltonian we have an
boundary law or an area law so the
entanglement just is just the size of
the boundary ok so again that the
intuition is the same things within the
bulk aren't contributing to the
entanglement around contributing much to
the entanglement if we if we have a
gapless system where I have a finite
number of zero energy modes or a direct
a direct point in my Fermi surface then
I still have a boundary law however if I
have a gapless system with a 1d Fermi
surface then I get a logarithmic
correction to my boundary law so we can
have this sort of table of entanglement
that we find in ground states of local
systems for 1d systems and 2d systems
and what we see is either we see a
boundary or an area law or with some
like slight correction a logarithmic
correction and ian's isit has a very
good review paper on area laws in the
quantum systems if you want to learn
more and this is what gives us hope in
that this is something we can do
efficiently is that these these ground
states of local systems have much less
entanglement than a generic entangled
state so clearly we can't just simulate
arbitrary things and in this regime
arbitrary quantum systems however these
cases are very very special have some
very special properties so they may it
might be feasible to try and do these
efficiently classically ok so can we
find ways of parameter izing area law or
boundary law states efficiently go
okay and one very productive way of
doing it is using these structures
called tensor networks which are also
just schematically before I go into
detail so the idea is a typical our
generic wave function is described by a
tensor with exponentially many
parameters so this is some very
complicated object I'm going to break
this down into a product of simpler
objects a product of small tensors that
I can describe each of these efficiently
okay so just to make things very clear I
have my quantum state sound in qubits
I'm describing these complex amplitudes
in this tensor okay with in indices okay
so if I just fix each of these legs it
tells me a complex number according to
the relating to the amplitude of some
state and now what I'm going to do is
just very quickly we're going to use a
graphical or diagrammatic notation to
represent these objects okay so if I
have a tensor of some number of Labe
legs is just a blob with or four lines
coming out of it whenever two tensors
share a line this represents a summation
or a contraction over this index okay so
we're going to consider states where
this coefficient tensor factorizes into
a product of smaller tensors okay so if
we try and do things with equations they
get very complicated and difficult to
understand but if we draw this out okay
so we've just partitioned sort of
linearly following the 1d lattice this
this tensor into a product of tensors
okay where we're summing over these
internal J indices
and we'll go into more detail about this
later on but so schematically we can
think about it
we had for this generic entangled state
arbitrarily high entanglement takes
exponentially many parameters to
describe this at the other end of the
scale we have a product state so this is
very boring we have no entanglement here
however we have an efficient
representation with order in parameters
describing the state so the tensor
network is an interpolation between
these two extremes okay so we have some
bond dimension Chi we call it which just
is the dimension of this index of Chi
equals 1 then we have a product state of
Chi is exponentially large then we can
recover any state up here so the hope is
is that for some reasonable values of
this bond dimension we still get some
entanglement and that this is enough to
do some interesting things ok so we can
really interpolate between these two
extreme cases in some controlled way
so given its okay and this is this one
here is called a matrix product state
just this one dimensional sequential
sort of partitioning of the state tensor
okay so given this general idea of
cutting this big coefficient tensor up
into a product of smaller tensors we now
can sort of see the rules of the game
there are many ways we could try and cut
a state tensor or represented as a
product of smaller tensors what makes a
representation useful and what once
should we consider in doing this so in
doing this kind of decomposition or this
kind of representation we want to have
an answer that's compatible with the
properties we expect in our state so we
want the correct entanglement or
correlation functions or mutual
information so this is the one we'll
focus on today and tang an entropy we
want efficient algorithms for
manipulating these structures so I want
to be able to optimize the parameters of
these tensors in some way as to give me
a good approximation to the ground state
of the system I'm interested in and we
want to of course be able to extract
information expectation values
correlation functions efficiently from
these structures and usually these two
things sort of go hand in hand
but that if I can evaluate things
efficiently then I have good ways of
optimizing the parameters as well okay
so these are two structures we're going
to compare from the beginning both
structures for 1d lattices of insights
both structures that have order n
parameters so matrix product state and
this one called multi scale and tainment
renormalization ansatz
or mirror so it's a much more
complicated structure however we
shouldn't be too scared I just have some
four and extensors and some three index
tensors okay and I organized my
tensor Network with an extra scale so
this is a length or an energy scale and
I'm just
so each layer has the structure and I
have log if I have in sites than I have
log in of these layers before I have no
more sites left and I stopped so this is
related to a coarse graining
transformation but we don't have to
think about that
for today it's just some structure of
tensors connected in a network so is
there some benefit for having this more
complicated structure that has this this
extra connectivity there in terms of
entanglement so let's look at these so
so the question we should ask is how
much entanglement can i reproduce with
this type of structure of this matrix
product states so I have a high
dimensional index connecting the tensors
I want to know how much entanglement can
this blockade possess okay so each
dimension or each index carries at most
log pi entanglement a and B are
connected by only two indices and this
is independent of the size of a and B
okay so I have a strict upper bound on
any state described by this matrix
product state the entanglement for some
block of sites is strictly upper bounded
at two times the log of the bond
dimension okay so this is a constant
that doesn't depend on the system size
okay when I look at this more
complicated structure if I ask how much
entanglement can I have between a and B
at least I can get a I can get a an
upper bound for what this entanglement
can be by asking the question of what is
the minimum number of wires I have to
cut in order to separate this region a
or the indices contained in this region
a from B okay so here I need to cut at
least four indices in order to separate
these two parts of the network if I
increase the size of a here I've doubled
the size of a then I need to cut at
least six indices to separate a from B
so this is an upper bound but and
practice's upper bound can be saturated
or at least the scaling of it so what we
see here is again the entanglement
depends on the log of the bond
dimension but it also scales with the
size of the block we're trying to
represent and so larger blocks can have
more entanglement and when we draw these
pictures this is how you should think of
it is it's really a geometries ation of
the entanglement and a wave function so
these indices carry entanglement between
different parts of the system the more
indices we have the more entanglement we
can have but potentially the more
difficult it can be to actually
manipulate these structures and to
evaluate them ok so here are my two
example structures for 1d you can see
where each of them may be useful and
that one reproduces the strict boundary
law for entangling it should be scaling
one reproduces this logarithmic
violation and in practice we find this
matrix product state is very good for
representing gaps gapped 1d systems you
can scale the very large system sizes
very accurately and this mera structure
is very useful for gapless or critical
1d systems and that you can really
reproduce the correct properties of a
lattice version of a conformal field
theory very accurately on larger
infinite system sizes so this was very
hand wavy there are more rigorous
statements say thanks to Hastings for
how well this matrix product states
works and more recently you can have at
least in simple cases you can have
analytic error bounds on how well this
mirror works for simple cases
their second order phase transition yes
so yes things corresponding to see if
T's and the continuance
okay so so these two structures
respectively reproduce the expected
properties of gapped and critical
systems and one dimension
can we so this is a statement about
these answers are they're useful and
practice can we actually have good
algorithms to minute to optimize these
structures so the problem we usually
have is we have some lattice Hamiltonian
we want to study we're going to randomly
initialize our matrix product state and
we want some variational algorithm to
optimize the free parameters as to give
us a good ground state approximation
okay so output is this good
approximation then we can evaluate
expectation values correlation functions
etc so DM RG is this there's most widely
used and probably the first sort of good
algorithm to do this manipulation this
optimization and practice this works
very well there are many other things
you can do here as well this is not
guaranteed to converge the ground state
you can have examples where this gets
stuck in local minima you have ways of
trying to avoid this but however there
is some very nice work rigorous out G
algorithms by vidiq reserve as irani
Landau and company that actually do have
proof that do provably converge these
are not variational methods over mps as
i understand them but related to this
and and the same thing for this mirror
structure you have efficient algorithms
that work at least most of the time or
it's not usually a problem we want to be
able to extract information from these
structures efficiently and just to give
you a picture of what this looks like so
here is the bra and the kit of a matrix
product state I want to evaluate for
some observable I can just do some
contraction of the top and the bottom
and then the thing I'm left to evaluate
in order to evaluate this expectation
value is just a product of a vector
multiplied by a matrix many times so
this is clearly an order in operation
this is something that's efficient okay
so and the mirror is similar and except
you have only login literation so these
are useful structures they reproduce the
correct properties these are things we
can optimize these are things we can
evaluate in general Marren know so
unfortunately this this is a I would say
this is a necessary condition but it's
not a sufficient condition write down an
example of a state that has the right
entropy but is clearly not correct so I
mean I could write down a mirror-like
structure that has log L scaling but
there are very good reasons why it could
not be a good approximation to the
ground state of a critical system yeah
it's it's a necessary condition but
certainly not sufficient in its own
right so very quickly do these lat do
these ideas generalize the higher
dimensions and the answer is yes we have
matrix product states can be generalized
to two-dimensional lattices these are
called projected entangled pair States
peps and I can build very similar
structures to these mirror and high
dimensional lattices as well and you can
very clearly see more hopefully very
clearly the how the entanglement scales
and these more complicated structures ok
so again if I just look at the number of
wires I have to cut in order to separate
an elbow region from the rest of the
lattices clearly order L indices so this
reproduces the boundary law for
entanglement entropy scaling so this is
what we have so far these are our
grounds and tankmen's and ground States
we have MPs is very naturally there 1d
mirrors here pips can do this out
scaling and there are examples of pips
that for critical systems so maybe you
might expect that 2d mirror lives over
here it turns out it doesn't so this is
a schematic representation of a layer of
2d mirror we just have these 4 by 4
tenses interlaced we ask the question of
how much entanglement can be in this
type of structure okay so just
schematically we're going through the
same manipulation where we look at an L
by L block and we ask what is the
minimum number of indices I have to cut
in order to separate this block from
everything else in the structure and you
see here I have order L wires I have to
cut at the lowest layer water L over 2 L
over 4 L over 8 all of these sum up just
to order L
okay so we have this very interesting
behavior where this 2d version of this
mirror reproduces only the strict
boundary lore not the logarithmic
correction so this was sort of an open
question for some time can we reproduce
this logarithmic Corrections the aerial
or efficiently with some some structure
that we can still manipulate efficiently
so that there is and we need a slightly
more sophisticated class of tintin at
work okay so a standard mirror is built
from sort of this this type of building
block we have a quantum state we
interlace the quantum state with some
zero qubits
okay so alternating and perform at
shallow say two level quantum circuit we
get a new state and we we repeat this
procedure and this the mirror is
precisely the classic quantum state that
can be build by iterating this procedure
so now in order to have the the
logarithmic scaling in two dimensions we
need a more sophisticated class of state
called a branching mirror okay and the
branching mirror is built from a very
similar sort of primitive block except
rather than initializing half the qubits
in the zero state we take some quantum
state some quantum state interlace them
perform a shallow quantum circuit and we
can repeat this procedure many times
okay and okay and and remarkably this
class the quantum state is still
something that's efficient to evaluate
we can still get expectation values and
linear number of steps a linear number
of qubits I was looking I was thinking
should be right and then let's just
start very Nabal if we just do a normal
mirror for ever you go so you don't give
a good contrast between a row bank
doesn't this feel like
I love them it's because it doesn't
because yeah it doesn't unless you have
a product if you just have a product of
1d mirror without any connections the
other way then that would be L logo but
as soon as you if you try and say do a
product of one day mirror and then a
product of one day mirror the other way
and do your 2d transformation just as a
alternating between one D then the sony
has our entanglement well layer on top
of a vertical so then we will reduce to
yes it's not not obvious and not clear
how would you think of what's happening
behind yes there is
unfortunately I won't have time to go
into it much in this talk but so the
short of it is so and 2d the this is
useful for cases with a Fermi surface
and you can imagine like I'm branches
are capturing different parts of the
Fermi surface so I'm kind of cutting it
into pieces or a simpler cases if I had
something like spin charge separation I
can have spin theory go into one branch
and the charges go into the other
something like that now you see that
it was perhaps like that sounds like a
feasible Judy Mira and branching Mayer
is still efficient in 2d everything is
still polynomial in the system size
and when I have these types of
structures so I have a standard mirror I
have this branching mirror with two
branches at every level so it looks like
a binary tree if I draw the branching
schematically I can have something in
between these two structures as well
where I have a little bit of branching
but not the most branching so there are
we call this a holographic tree
describing this branching structure and
I have two diversions of the structure
that get very complicated to draw and to
implement but when you look at the
entanglement okay so I have a 2d box
branching mirror I have branches sort of
with a binary tree so two branches at
each level when I compute the
entanglement entropy from a block I add
up all the contributions I have these
additive contributions from each branch
and I have more branches at the higher
levels okay so when I add these all
together it equates to owl entanglement
or doral entanglement from each level so
this sums to log L so i reproduce my
logarithmic violation Sintang when area
law and there are at least in simple
cases we can have rigorous error bounds
showing that this branching mirror works
and relatively simple cases okay so
there is at least one state ground state
in here that you can prove the structure
is the correct one so between all of
these different types of network we've
seem to have got or properly reproduced
all of the entanglement we expect to
find at least in common ground States
so we have the correct scaling Matanga
and entropy we want efficient algorithms
for manipulating these structures so
with peps and mirror we doing pretty
well this branching mirror is still very
difficult in practice we want to be able
to evaluate things efficiently this peps
now exact evaluation is provably
difficult
it's an sharpy complexity however we
have very good approximation algorithms
for getting information from peps so
usually in practice is not so bad these
other structures a 2d mirror and
branching mirror are things you can
evaluate from efficiently order in time
so wrapping up here so in practice how
good of these methods practice peps is
getting very good ok so it was only a
few years ago it was probably too
expensive to be much use but now
algorithms are getting better methods
earlier every everything surrounding it
is improving and getting better and
people like Corbeau having very
impressive results for these very
difficult problems like the 2d TJ model
and hubbard model that have been sort of
long-standing very difficult problems
thinking it's matter this mera structure
is at probably at this moment too
difficult or too expensive to be viable
for difficult problems so we just need
more algorithmic development smarter
ways to do the algorithm smarter ways to
contract things and do the manipulations
ok so let me just summarize so our goal
is to at least we want this simple goal
to begin with of simulating or finding
ground sites of lattice systems that
have local interactions ok and
optimistically I would say that this is
something that seems to be within reach
ok we've got at least some of the way
there and it looks like this is a class
of problem which is tractable to this
type of classical simulation
okay so and in general hopefully
anything sort of with a boundary law
could be or most things could be
enriched to classical simulation so what
needs to be done well I would say a lot
of these 2d methods we need much better
practical algorithms okay so they're
more efficient and how we do things how
we do these manipulations we want better
theoretical understanding okay so with
1d we have very good proofs and
guarantees and provably converging
algorithms will be very nice to have
this type of thing in 2d as well okay
and and there is some work in this
direction like we can have some error
balance for pips some error balance for
mirror in certain cases but certainly
nowhere near the situation in 1d where
things are much more rigorously
understood and developed okay and we
also want to move beyond these simple
lattice models so more realistic
materials so multiple orbits per site
orbitals beside long-range interactions
so now you need to consider basis sets
and things get much more complicated and
all everything I was talking about was
for ground state physics so we want to
be able to do dynamics open systems so
other types of problem as well and in
particular dynamics are much more
difficult you have this growth of
entanglement typically so these methods
at least the simple variants of these
methods tend to break down very quickly
with this type of thing alright thanks
for attention
[Applause]
so at the beginning you started showing
like how they kind of the memory
requirement we grow with depending on
the size of their say in college do you
have numbers for what these levels can
do at the moment like the one that you
just have an idea so the the idea behind
what's the idea behind all of these
methods is that if you reproduce the
proper amount of entanglement you expect
in the wave function then the cost of
that cost is going to be in in the
system size or like
so in general what we do is we just
directly go to the infinite system
directly I mean because we have
translation of variants then we can just
use the same tensor in each spot so
we're really not we've shifted the
problem of increasing system size as
something we can get for free or very
easy but we need to be able to increase
the entanglement okay so we the system
size is not the concern and there's no
it's really just we have a hill to get
over for having enough int Angwin once
we're over the hill we can do as big as
system as we want they are
computationally intensive is just the
system size is not the relevant
parameter anymore it's the amount of
entanglement so big system or small
system I don't care how much
entanglement whether the prefactor
before the area law becomes the
important thing but anything with the
area law is in principle tractable now
for large systems
a little bit more about the branching
era in practices is it a is it a viable
way to attack to the problems and what
what's not
in general it's very difficult to
optimize I would say like in principle
everything's there and it's sufficient
and you can show that you can reproduce
the correct entanglement scalings and
other things
in practice I mean it's just I would
like to have a very good graduate
student work on this for some time and I
think you would have a you have a
difficult project and actually
implementing this but it's something
that heuristics to go through the
tensors as you have for the OSD MRG does
in what do you so my experience with
this has been that it's much harder to
converge in a proper way like you have
you're trying to separate the physics
off into two branches so doing
everything like you have some methods we
can locally update each tensor by trying
to
that may not converge the correct thing
to do there is that you mentioned four
EPS and the other thing these they're
just on this sweet Lydia - yes thanks
sweet this sweeping yeah so you could
and in like ideally you'd have like say
if I have some manifold of zero modes
one branch will be capturing some of it
one branch will be capturing the rest of
it and practice if I try and optimize
this maybe one branch just tries to do
everything in the other branch just
something trivial and it's very hard to
smoothly go between these two cases
where one branch is doing something
trivial to positioning it so the
variational problem is much harder I
don't know whether this is amenable to
doing just the local sweep overall
tenses in general do this you are trying
to create the state and either talking
about characteristics in the state but
how do you know how close you are to the
state you want I mean do you have a way
of measuring that or nulling besides
you're looking at an attribute of the
state usually we're looking at the
energy so you can evaluate the energy of
your state you can evaluate how the
energy scales as you increase the
dimension of these indices whether it's
going you can evaluate the variance of
the energy to figure out whether you're
in an eigenstate or not but in general
like you don't have a guarantee
in Kate and like in other cases like DMR
G you have very good and you can
understand the truncation error more
accurately so it's sometimes the energy
is not a good metric but you have these
other ones like related to how much
error is involved in each truncation
that you can have better understanding
as well branching mirrors did you see
that the rigorous results for some cases
for for the for showing that if you can
represent them before including also and
harder than for or efficiently for even
for special cases for these special
cases you can actually analytically come
up with these tenses the different
dimensions based is based on some weight
like you can show that this relates to a
wavelet transformation you can build
solutions from knowing wavelets that
have some convergence to the exact
result not variational
the aerial I found effective it can use
using that is sufficient to give States
their tendencies
yes that's the that's been done with
these mirror and with these pips you
have to do something else rather than
variation or energy minimization of
course so usually if I have
one way of doing this is by using a path
integral formula 'sm where you represent
e to the minus beta H so path integral
and you have a way of turning this into
the tinsel network okay so well
imaginary time evolution versions of
these algorithms sorry
usually quite difficult so there are
some things you can do in parallel but
usually the method you have for an
answer as you sweep over every unique
tensor and you go a little bit in the
right direction so you can try and do
different tenses at the same time but
you like parallelizing beyond say a few
hundred CPUs is probably very difficult
like it's not like Monte Carlo we can go
tens of thousands very easily
so you mentioned dynamics as a you know
possible future direction or other
situations where you might might hope
that you contracted Lisa Miele dynamics
I mean I would somehow imagine it even
for like gapped one-dimensional systems
it'll be quite hard to do that with with
classical methods but are there other
cases you have in mind where you think
this might actually be something you
could do efficiently I think it's it's
not out of reach I mean there are many
people have had proposals where they can
do some types of dynamics efficiently
maybe you don't need to follow the
dynamics you just want the long like the
steady state source there are there are
things that can be done I don't think
it's intractable
upset
[Applause]